-My first guests
are global pop music icons.
They've had
four number-one songs
on the Billboard Hot 100
in less than a year.
Their latest song,
"Permission to Dance,"
is out now, and it's available
on the "Butter" CD single.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome BTS!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Come on!
Look at you guys!
Look at you!
Welcome back!
-What's popping? How you doing?
-Jimmy!
-Now, I'm doing great, guys.
I'm so happy you're here.
Yeah, I love those suspenders,
bud.
Now, since
your first appearance,
we talked
about Grammy nominations
and what it would mean to you
every single time.
Well, it finally happened.
"Dynamite" was nominated
for a Grammy.
Congratulations on that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, a Grammy!
-What was that like for you,
and how did it feel?
-Sorry for the cliche, but,
you know, it's really an honor.
You know, it's one of the
biggest honors as an artist
for, of course,
throughout the world.
And it's the first time
as a Korean,
and, you know, that's
so meaningful, so historic.
And just,
we couldn't, like, realize it.
And I'm so happy, so crazy,
and so thankful for all the fans
all over the world.
That's it.
-I have a good feeling
that you're gonna win a Grammy
soon enough,
because "Butter"
is number-one on the Hot 100
for the 7th week in a row.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The video...
-Amazing!
-The video has almost
half a billion views.
I have a feeling it's gonna be
the song of the summer.
How did you know that "Butter"
was gonna work?
-Oh!
-[ Speaking in Korean ]
-Ah, yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I like in the "Butter" video,
at one point you spell out
army using your bodies.
And I'm sure the army
appreciates it, too.
Yeah. "A" I can get. Yeah.
"R" is pretty -- "R"
is pretty easy. It's like "R."
And them "M" would be this.
And then that, you know?
Anyways, you did it much cooler,
but I will say
Jin and Jungkook, tell me
about creating the "A,"
because that doesn't look
easy for me.
-[ Laughs ]
-Ooh!
-[ Speaking in Korean ]
-Okay. Let's go. Let's go.
-That's what I'm talking about!
-Let's go, let's go.
-Yeah! Aw!
-Easy.
-Easy peasy lemon squeezy!
-Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
-Yeah.
-Easy. Easy.
-Easy peasy. It wasn't hard.
-[ Laughs ]
You get it in one take, yeah.
On Friday, you released the new
single "Permission to Dance."
Tell me how this song came
together.
-So, "PTD" is a song that will
get everybody's heart pumping
and dancing again, and, you
know, this is a, actually, gift
of Ed Sheeran, of course,
one of our friends.
Mad respect. Big love to Ed.
And we also prepared something
called
"Permission to Dance" Challenge
with YouTube Shorts,
so please stay tuned for more.
"PTD," let's go.
-Wow.
Did you -- Do you remember
when you first met Ed Sheeran?
-Oh, we can't believe that we
haven't met him yet.
And, you know, this is
the second project with him,
but we never met him yet.
-Is that right? That's wild.
I mean, 'cause I have some
ideas, and we actually have met.
So, I know you better
than Ed Sheeran.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, of course. Of course.
-Yeah, so I have some song ideas
if you want.
You know, if you want to work
in the "Butter" category,
I can go all through
the dairy aisle.
Whatever you think of, you let
me know and we'll get together.
Just get on the phone,
we'll Zoom, we'll FaceTime.
We'll figure it out.
-Let's go!
-Zoom, Zoom, Zoom! Let's go.
-Maybe cheesecake or cereal.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's what I'll do. I'll
work on "Cereal" with you guys.
I was excited to see you guys go
on tour, "Map of the Soul" tour,
and then the pandemic happened.
I didn't get a chance to see it
or open for you guys.
And so -- You never asked.
But I was thinking when --
when will you go back on tour,
and what will that feel like
when you do go back on tour?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Make some noise! Yeah!
-Whoo-hoo!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-This is what we want, and
this is what we're gonna feel
when we're back on tour.
We want to do the
"make some noise" thing again.
-Getting out there, even for
like 10 people, then 50,
and now finally a full audience,
it's emotional just for me.
I'm just preparing you
for an emotional...
an emotional first performance,
yeah.
Wear sunglasses.
[ Laughter ]
-Get ready, guys, get ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
-Speaking of sunglasses,
I have a photo of your first
show eight years ago
when BTS just started.
Can you look at yourselves here?
Which one of you guys
is wearing the sunglasses
in the darkest room
I've ever seen in my life?
-Oh!
-Wow.
-Actually, it's me...
-Oh!
-It's very hilarious.
-Ooh.
-Jimin! Jimin, turn around!
-Jimin!
-Jimin, turn around.
Jimin, look --
[ Laughs ]
-Be confident. Be confident.
-Oh, my goodness.
It's great.
But what goes through your mind
when you see something --
I won't show it anymore.
But what do you think when you
see that?
That was only eight years ago,
not too long ago.
[ All speaking in Korean ]
-Yeah.
-We got --
Actually, we think we got
handsome.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, no, hey. No.
I think...
I think you've always had that.
Now, look, I want to
get to the bottom
of some BTS rumors
that are out there.
More with BTS when we come back,
everybody. Come on back!